[Music]
the n-c-double-a your alma mater
Michigan State Michigan State okay in
the sweet 16
your predictions you think they're going
all the way I think we're going all the
way we got Duke it's gonna be a war but
they will win is it this tournament
maybe the most even tournament we've
seen in some time because anybody can
win it Indiana you got oh hi Oh state
Louisville looks good so you got
Syracuse you got a number of teams that
can actually win it I'm crossing my
fingers for my Michigan State Spartans
Florida Gulf Coast everybody's talking
about what are just a great Cinderella
story this is is this for real
could it be for Rio no it's definitely
for real because you don't win you be
upset Georgetown and then if it wasn't
for real they would have lost the second
game just one what on Sunday again it's
an amazing story exactly and this what
can happen when it's not won game series
right see that's why it's March Madness
is so wonderful is because it only takes
one game anything can happen anything
can happen let's change it up here you
wanted to talk about something make
knowing your thing and this is crucially
important explain what make knowing your
thing but what it is is now people
should know their status when it comes
to HIV and AIDS I've lived with it now
for 22 years
god blessed me with good health and then
thank you that people go get tested to
end go back and get their results in or
quick has come up with a in-home test
where you can just take it in your home
and the privacy of your home to find out
if you have HIV or not we want to show
this because it's really important it is
a test that you can purchase this test
yes you can find out and what people
need to know is they can there's a lot
they can do that's what they can do to
to help them live with this disease yeah
early detection saved my life it can
save anybody's life and especially in
the african-american community and the
Latino community because the numbers are
very high in our community go out and
get tested get your do it in your own
the compounds of your own home with this
quick test only takes you your results
in twenty minutes and there's no needle
now you just
WOB your mouth really easy and quick
it's amazing you mentioned was it
twenty-two years your diagnosis and at
the time a lot of people thought for you
the thinking of the time is that's a
death sentence is that how you felt at
the time I was questioning whether it
was or not because there was nobody that
I knew what lived a long time with HIV
or AIDS okay I was seeing my how what's
going to happen to me but the drugs got
better my wife stayed with me and
supported me my family supported me and
my kids so it's and then the Lakers
players and organizations supported me
so this town has been wonderful to me
and I owe a lot to all of you so thank
you for your prayers that's it for more
information about the make knowing your
thing campaign go to or aquick dot-com
slash knowing magic always an honor
[Applause]